فِى مَنْزلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ
دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
مَنْ بِالْبَابْ
اسْتَلِمُوا مِنِّى الطَلَبِيَّةْ
بِيتْزَا سَاخِنَةٌ وَشَهِيَّةْ
ومَعَهَا أُخْرَى مَجَّانِيَّةْ
صَوْتُكَ خَشِنٌ أنْتَ الثَّعْلبْ
اذْهَبْ اذْهَبْ يَا كَذَّابْ
مَا دَامَتْ مَامَا بِالخَارِجِ
لَنْ نُدْخِلَ أَبَداً أَغْرَابْ
فِى مَنْزلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ
دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
من بالباب
افْتَحُوا لِي أَنَا مِسْكِينْ
أَعْطُونِي تمرا و طحين
وَلَكُمْ أَجْرُ المُحْسِنِينْ
صوتك خشن أَنْتَ الثَّعْلبْ
اِذْهَبْ اذْهَبْ يَا كَذَّابْ
مَادَامَتْ مَامَا بِالخَارِجْ
لَنْ نُدْخِلَ أَبَداً أَغْرَابْ
فِى مَنْزلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ
دق دق الباب
دق دق  دق
مَنْ بِالْبَابْ
أَنَا مُحَصِّلُ التَيَّارْ
اِفْتَحُوا لِي يَا شُطَّارْ
قبل أن أظْلِمْ الدار
صَوْتُكَ خَشِنٌ أَنْتَ الثَّعْلَبْ
اذْهَبْ اذْهَبْ يا كَذَّابْ
مادامت ماما بالخارج
لن ندخل أبدا أغراب
اوه لا لا لا
فِى مَنْزلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ
دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
من بالباب
أَنَا مَامَا يَا أَحْبَابِي
أَقِفُ الآَنَ أَمَامَ البَابْ
افْتَحُوا لِي يا أولادي
أَهْلاً ثَعْلُوبُ الكَذَّابْ
أَنَا مَامَا خَلْفَ البَابْ
ها ها ها ها   ها ها ها ها
يَاوَيْلِي مَامَا سَمِعَتْنِي
وَسَأَهْرُبُ كَي لا تُمْسِكَنِي
هاهاها يا كذاب
أنت الثعلب هيا اذهب
لا لن نفتح هذا الباب